hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live es klingt wie aus einem Krimi
Anschläge auf Pipelines und Kabel im
Meer seit letztem Jahr wissen wir dass
es keine Fiktion sondern Realität
geworden in der Ostsee auch sieben
Monate später ist immer noch nicht klar
wer die beiden nordstream Pipelines
gesprengt hat und es gibt auch schon
wieder neue sorgen in einer Recherche
der britischen Zeitung The Times heißt
es Russland soll mehrere europäische
Unterwasserkabel und Pipelines vermiet
haben die Info kommt von einem NATO
Mitarbeiter über diese Vorwürfe und wie
die NATO sich schützen möchte darüber
wollen wir heute mit euch sprechen
schreibt gerne eure Kommentare dazu live
in den Stream oder schickt sie uns auch
per Mail stellt Fragen denn darum soll
es bei uns gehen sind Anschläge auf
unsere Infrastruktur im Meer geplant und
wir können darüber sprechen mit einem
Experten das ist Fregattenkapitän Göran
der jetzt bei uns ist erforscht genau zu
dem Thema für die Stiftung Wissenschaft
und Politik schönen guten Abend Herr
Sistig schönen guten Abend Herr swiszek
geh mir direkt mal auf diese Vorwürfe
ein glauben sie dass da was dran ist
also das Russland mehrere
Unterwasserkabel und Pipelines wirklich
vermiet haben könnte ich persönlich
halte das für sehr wahrscheinlich wir
haben den letzten Jahren zahlreiche
Aktivitäten Russlands gesehen dass man
sich gerade militärischen Bereich neue
Fähigkeiten im Unterwasserbereich
zugelegt hat diese erprobt hat und wir
haben sehr viel Aktivitäten russische
militärischer Schiffe aber auch ziviler
Schiffe entlang kritischer Infrastruktur
in den letzten zwei Jahren verzeichnet
Datenkabel Pipelines Offshore Windparks
überall dort haben wir Aktivitäten von
russischen Schiffen gesehen es ist
durchaus vorstellbar dass man hier nicht
nur aus Spielversuche betrieben hat
sondern auch schon Vorbereitung
getroffen hat um vielleicht später für
einen möglichen Fall diese kritische
Infrastruktur zu nutzen um sie zu
sabotieren
sie haben eben von aussperr Versuchen
gesprochen also auch der
stellvertretende Nato-Generalsekretär
David kattler der hatte sich geäußert
sagte Russland würde aktuell die
Infrastruktur von westlichen Partnern
der Ukraine aktiv kartieren sowohl zu
Land als auch zu Wasser ist das denn
gleich verdächtig oder ist sowas
vielleicht sogar üblich können Sie uns
dazu mal aufklären na die Frage die man
sich hier stellen kann ist warum
cartiere ich das warum will ich die
Informationen haben wozu will ich sie
nutzen will ich diese nutzen um den
anderen Staaten zu schaden um eigene
Mittel einzusetzen vielleicht auch als
verlängerten Hebel um auf diese Staaten
einwirken zu können oder um diese
Staaten vielleicht am Ende sogar zu
destabilisieren und das ist ein durchaus
vorstellbares Szenario
sie arbeiten aktuell ganz aktuell zu
einer Studie zur kritischen
infrastrukturkritischen Unterwasser
Infrastruktur was da besonders gefährdet
ist was sind denn ihre Erkenntnisse
jetzt aktuell
in der Tat arbeite ich zurzeit mit
mehreren herausragenden Kollegen von der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik zum
Thema maritimer kritischer
Infrastrukturen wir haben versucht
verschiedene Expertise zusammenzubringen
es gibt ja zahlreiche Infrastrukturen in
maritimen Raum deren Anzahl hatten den
letzten Jahren stetig zugenommen wir
haben Datenkabel wir haben Pipelines wir
haben offshore Bohrinseln wir haben
Offshore Windparks und wir haben dann
auch Seewege die immer stärker genutzt
werden für den Handel diese Expertise
bringen wir zusammen und durchleuchten
einmal inwiefern diese Infrastruktur
bereits das Kriterium der Kritikalität
besitzt wie fern sie uns beeinflussen
unsere Gesellschaften beeinflussen wie
fern Sie auch unsere Sicherheit
beeinflussen können und was man zu deren
Schutz tun kann wir sind natürlich
darauf gekommen dass einzelne Datenkabel
einzelne Pipelines einzelne Offshore
Windparks gar nicht so kritisch sind
weil die meisten unserer westlichen
staatengesellschaften
ihre Versorgungswege stark
diversifiziert haben das heißt wir haben
mehrere Quellen aus denen wir zum
Beispiel Energie beziehen unsere ähnlich
ist es auch beim Transport und Handel
aber eine Schädigung gerade mehrere
dieser Infrastrukturen könnte dann schon
signifikante Folgen auf starten und
Gesellschaften haben
sie haben es gerade angesprochen also es
gibt mehrere Infrastrukturen die wir
aktuell nutzen gesehen haben wir als sie
gesprochen haben welche Unterwasserkabel
und Pipelines aber im Zweifel für uns
also in Deutschland dann auch gefährdend
wären was würde uns denn besonders
Treffen habe ich Sie richtig verstanden
ist es dass wenn wir jetzt auch in
mehreren Punkten angegriffen werden
würden richtig wenn dann mehreren
Punkten angegriffen oder diese zerstört
werden würde oder wenn wir gleich
mehrere Arten von Infrastruktur von
einer Zerstörung betroffen hätten so
haben wir in der Nordsee zum Beispiel
relativ viel maritime Infrastruktur wir
haben Datenkabel wir haben Pipelines wir
haben offshoreboy Inseln wir haben
Offshore Windparks das in der ganzen
Kombination auf einen relativ
geographisch beschränkten Raum macht es
natürlich für eine Akteur der da ein
Schaden beifügen will umso leichter die
ist auch durchzuführen zu planen und
wenn diese Infrastruktur betroffen wäre
würden mehrere Branchen Sektoren
gleichzeitig betroffen und nicht zu
vergessen die Nordsee ist auch ein
Dichter Seewege für den Handel nach
Hamburg Bremerhaven unsere großen Häfen
über die unsere Wirtschaft auch ihre
Güter bekommt bzw auch dann wieder
exportiert wer da eine Schädigung würde
deine Schädigung vorliegen werden auch
die Seewege betroffen das hätte also
einen nachhaltigen und kaskadenartigen
Effekt auf unsere Gesellschaft auf
unsere Wirtschaft dazu passt die Frage
bei uns im Stream bei Youtube von Verdi
GHG er oder sie möchte wissen glauben
sie das auch Pipelines in Europa
zwischen Skandinavien und im Ärmelkanal
betroffen sind
möglich ist das ja vorstellbar ist das
und sie forschen auch dazu dazu kommen
wir auch noch in dieser Sendung wie man
sich besser schützen kann aber gehen wir
auch zuerst noch mal über eben die Sorge
vor tatsächlich ein Angriffen ein denn
die ist ja nicht ganz unbegründet die
kommt nicht von ungefähr es gab also
eben letztes Jahr wir erinnern uns mit
Sicherheit alle die Situation im
September dass die Pipelines nordstream
1 und 2 angegriffen wurden Explosionen
gab es dort an Teilen der Pipelines und
seitdem ist auch eine Sondergruppe
eingesetzt um die Sicherheit eben dieser
Untersee Infrastruktur in der Nord- und
Ostsee besser zu prüfen und zu schützen
und eben gegebenenfalls dann auch
Schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen zu können dazu
hatte ich eine Frage hier im Stream
gesehen die sehr gut dazu passt wenn
unten dabei bei Facebook fragt sich was
bedeutet das für die Arbeit der
Aufklärung Deutschland europäischer
westlicher Geheimdienste müsste nicht
diese kritische Infrastruktur besonders
geschützt werden man fragt sich nämlich
warum ist es denn bislang nicht passiert
naja fangen wir mal damit an das dem
maritime Raum oder die Ozeane das Meer
etwa 70 Prozent der Erdoberfläche
ausmachen und man geht davon aus dass
man bisher etwa zehn Prozent oder
weniger als 10% dieses Raumes wirklich
auf Karten erfasst hat wirklich weiß was
dort äh alles so
vorliegt wie dieser Raum aufgebaut ist
das ganze mal genommen haben wir auch
noch ein ganz großen Raum in dem Meeren
der wir noch gar nicht so erfasst ist wo
wir gar nicht wissen wie dieser Raum
eigentlich aufgebaut ist und trotzdem
verlegen wir dort bereits Datenkabel
haben Pipeline dort oder errichten ähm
Bohrinseln und werden diese Räume auch
weiterhin groß nutzen diesen ganzen Raum
komplett in ein Lagebild zu erfassen ist
sehr schwierig es gibt erste Maßnahmen
des Lagebild zu er weiterhin zu
verbessern und unter anderem zum
Beispiel durch Satellitenbilder aber
auch andere Maßnahmen diese muss man
alle in einem fusionierten Lage wird
vielleicht zusammen führen um besser zu
wissen was auf dem Meer und unter dem
Meer vor sich geht gerade unter dem Meer
ist es ja schwierig dass zum Beispiel
durch Satelliten zu erfassen welche
Aktivitäten davon starten gehen und was
sich da alles befindet
und eben habe ich schon angesprochen
also diesen Vorfall im letzten Jahr
wieso weiß man eigentlich noch nicht
ganz sicher wer das war jetzt diese
Sprengung der Pipelines Nord Stream 1
und 2 Spekulationen dazu gibt es viele
aber wieso ist das immer noch nicht
geklärt
gerade die unterwasserdomäne bietet ja
wie ich das gerade auch schon ausgeführt
habe den Ansatz verdeckt zu operieren
dadurch dass ich das nicht durch
Satellitenbilder erfassen kann dass ich
eigentlich Sensoren vor Ort haben müsste
unter Wasser schallsensoren hydraphische
Sensoren die eine Bewegung aufzeichnen
und die habe ich nicht überall deswegen
ist es relativ einfach unter Wasser
verdeckt zu operieren und vielleicht am
Rande auch mal der Nord Stream 1 und 2
Vorfall war jetzt der der meisten medial
Aufmerksamkeit erregt hat das war aber
nicht der erste Vorfall seiner Art wir
haben den letzten zwei Jahren schon
mehrere Vorfälle von Sabotage Akten
registriert die auch eine wirklich große
Auswirkung hatten zum Beispiel gab es im
Jahr 2021 von Norwegen ein Sabotage sagt
an Sensoren die dort einen
Forschungsinstitut für Meeresforschung
ausgebracht hatte die mehr als 60
Kilometer Raum umfassten und diese waren
nahe von nato-übungsgebieten diese
wurden über eine Länge von 3 Kilometern
zerstört die Kabel die zu diesen
Sensoren führten aber auch die Sensoren
selber dann hatten wir Anfang letzten
Jahres im Jahr 2022 die Zerstörung eines
Kabels das nach Spitzbergen führt eines
Datenkabels was das norwegische Festland
mit der Insel Spitzbergen und
insbesondere eine Satellitenstation
Sword Art genannt verbindet diese
Satellitenstation ist eine der größten
auf dieser Welt und aufgrund ihrer Lage
soweit im hohen Norden und durch die
Erdrotation kann sie eigentlich über den
Tag hinaus die meisten Satelliten
erreichen und kontinuierlich Daten
versenden da wurde eins von zwei Daten
Kabel auf einer Wassertiefe von
wahrscheinlich mehr als 400 m zerstört
das hatte ein nachhaltigen Effekt
und das sind nicht die einzigen Vorfälle
wir haben auch Vorfälle an Stromtrassen
Stromkabel registriert es gab auch
Vorfälle im Mittelmeer an drei
Datenkabeln zugleich aber nordstream war
das was jetzt am meisten in den Medien
auch wahrgenommen wurde es gibt auch bei
uns viel Diskussionen darüber gerade im
Chat also war da Russland beteiligt oder
eben nicht da wäre es jetzt vielleicht
ganz gut wenn wir da waren noch ein
bisschen tiefer einsteigen denn es gibt
Recherchen von skandinavischen und
finnischen Journalisten das russische
Schiffe mit diesen nordstream Anschlägen
eben in Verbindung stehen könnten darauf
deuten Funksprüche hin die ein Ex-Marine
Offizier mitgehört hat diese Recherchen
von den skandinavischen finnischen
Kollegen die haben Sie mit unseren
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von Frontal
geteilt wir haben einen Bericht dazu
schauen den gemeinsam ansprechen dann
darüber
jahrelang hat er für den britischen
Geheimdienst gearbeitet Funksprüche
russischer Schiffe abgehört jetzt
spricht James der eigentlich anders
heißt mit Journalisten erst mittlerweile
Rentner aber heimlich lauscht er noch
immer in die Ostsee im vergangenen Juni
drei Monate vor der Nord Stream Sabotage
hört er erstaunliches
seit zweieinhalb Jahren sitze ich hier
jeden Tag und beobachte die Ostseeflotte
es ist das einzige Mal dass ich diese
Typen in dieser Gegend beobachtet habe
es sind die Routen zweier russischer
Marineschiffe die die Aufmerksamkeit von
James erregt haben rund drei Monate vor
den Explosionen verlässt eine russisches
Schiff sein Stützpunkt in Kaliningrad
erreicht am 7 juni das Gebiet in dem
später die Nord Stream Pipelines
gesprengt wurden und fährt nach
dreistündigem Aufenthalt zurück in
Russland nur eine Woche später das
zweite russische Boot an der nördlichen
sabotagestelle die sie mir Jakob Kreuz
14 und 15 Juni im explosionsgebiet auch
sie kehrt anschließend nach Russland
zurück
das ist ein bekanntes
unterstützungsschiff für U-Boote es ist
zu unterwasserüberwachung Fähigkeit
russische Schiffe über den sabotageorden
Journalisten der nordischen
Rundfunkanstalten NRK D rsvt und Uhle
berichten jetzt in der neuen Doku-Serie
Putins Schattenkrieg über die Recherchen
von James die Erkenntnisse für
marineexperten bemerkenswert
all diese Aktivitäten zusammengenommen
ergeben ein Bild das in direktem
Zusammenhang mit dem nord-stream Vorfall
steht ich nehme nicht an dass das ein
Zufall ist
der wohl größte Sabotageakt unserer Zeit
gelöst ist das nordstream Rätsel noch
immer nicht spuren aber gibt's
mittlerweile reichlich eine davon die
Segelyacht Andromeda an Bord fanden
deutsche Ermittler sprengstoff-
doch auch Richtung Moskau führen Spuren
erst kürzlich wurde bekannt wenige Tage
vor der Explosion waren russische
Schiffe vor Ort dazu kommen jetzt die
Schiffsbewegung drei Monate und damit
deutlich vor den Anschlägen für
marineexperten wenn wohl eher eine
Mission zum auskundschaften
Roderich Kiesewetter sieht in den
Schiffsbewegungen keine Beweise jedoch
starke Hinweise es gibt keine
Vorfestlegungen aber die Ermittlungen
müssen ohne Einfluss von außen erfolgen
und deswegen darf auch nichts
ausgeschlossen werden erst recht auch
Russland nicht
sieben Monate ist es her dass diese
Bilder um die Welt gingen das Wasser der
Ostsee hat sich wieder beruhigt die
Theorien aber sprudeln weiter
[Musik]
verschiedene Theorien einmal wir haben
es gehört der Hinweis auf eine
ukrainische Gruppe dann eben dieses
russische Marineschiff das ist da jetzt
neu die sieben vorher Monate vorher
schon dort unterwegs war was halten Sie
für wahrscheinlicher und warum
fangen wir gleich mit dem Warum an
ich bin oder ich habe bei diesem Vorfall
gerne ein Hilfsmittel aus der
terrorismusforschung genutzt wo man nach
Plausibilitäten untersucht und dabei
fragt man zuerst nach dem Möglichkeiten
den Fähigkeiten und dann nach der
Intention Wert also die Möglichkeiten
solch einen Anschlag durchzuführen wer
hat die Fähigkeiten und wem nützt das
wie was ist das Ziel dahinter also die
Intention wenn ich das alles drei
Versuche zueinander zu bringen gerade
bei den Fähigkeiten und Möglichkeiten
aber auch dem Ziel komme ich immer
wieder auf einen staatlichen Akteur
kleinere Gruppen wie es in einigen
Recherchen mal durchgeklungen ist sind
hier nicht plausibel zu dem konkreten
Fall der hier jetzt dargestellt wurde
mit der 7 jahrhoff
halte ich das Verhalten im Juni per se
erstmal nicht so auffällig die Siebener
jakob ist ein Forschungsschiff ein
hydrografisches Forschungsschiff das
dafür ausgerichtet ist ausgestattet ist
den Unterwasserbereich aufzuzeichnen ein
Lagebild unter Wasser zu erstellen sie
hat zu diesem Zeitpunkt einen russisches
U-Boot begleitet in der Ostsee das ist
normales Verhalten wenn ein U-Boot zu
Übungszwecken eingesetzt wird weil man
gerade auch bei Unfällen mit einem
Schiff dann vor Ort sein will und ein
Lagebild über die Situation haben will
gleichzeitig der Monat Juni hat zwei
Bedeutungen für Russland ist das und
insbesondere die Seestreitkräfte ist der
juni so ziemlich der Abschluss eines
Ausbildungsjahres dann werden die
intensivsten Übungen durchgeführt bevor
dann eine kurze Sommerpause Eintritt und
man dann im Herbst wieder in einen neuen
Einsatz Ausbildungsabschnitt geht das
heißt die Präsenz dieser Schiffe ist im
Juni auch gar nicht so auffällig
gleichzeitig hat die NATO im Juni in
demselben Seegebiet die Übung bords
durchgeführt da ist es auch normal das
russische Schiffe vor Ort sind
gucken was die NATO Schiffe in dem
Bereich machen und da auch NATO U-Boote
oder U-Boote aus Partner Nationen aus
Schweden zum Beispiel eingesetzt werden
ist es auch normal dass man guckt was
passiert im Unterwasserbereich das mal
zusammen genommen ist das Verhalten noch
gar nicht so auffällig von der sieberia
Kopf wenn ich jetzt etwas genauer
reinzoom und mir die Fahrtrouten der sie
wieder Jakob angucke ist es schon
auffällig dass sie mehrfach über dem
Punkt der späteren Anschläge der
nordseepipeline gesteuert ist gefahren
ist dass sie diese Strecke teilweise
entlang des Strangs der Nord Stream
Pipeline wiederholt verfolgt hat das ist
schon auffällig und vorstellbar ist hier
so ist es ja auch ein Bericht
durchgeklungen das hier ein Lagebild
erstellt wurde Informationen gesammelt
wurden für vielleicht spätere Vorhaben
von denen die Besatzung der Silber ja
Kauf zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch keine
Ahnung hatte
wir haben also zwei Vorwürfe die im Raum
stehen einmal eben die russische
Beteiligung oder eben die russischen
Schiffe die im Zusammenhang stehen
sollen so heißt es richtigerweise im
Zusammenhang stehen sollen mit den
nordstream Anschlägen und einmal womit
wenn am Anfang der Sendung natürlich
aufgemacht haben und darüber gesprochen
haben dass Russland jetzt auch schon
unter sie Kabel und Pipelines vermiet
haben soll und wir haben kritische User
Fragen dazu einmal fragt sich wenn wir
jetzt noch kurz bei der Nord Stream
Pipelines bleiben anonym bei Youtube
weshalb sollte Russland die eigene teure
Pipeline sprengen das macht für für Sie
vielleicht wenig Sinn was würden Sie
darauf antworten
als die Sabotage durchgeführt wurde und
die beiden Stränge von Nordstemmen 1 und
ein Strang von Nord Stream 2 zerstört
wurden ist de facto kein Gas durch diese
Pipelines geflossen Nord Stream 1 war im
Wartungsintervall wurde gerade nicht
genutzt und das war absehbar das nur zum
eins auch nicht wieder genutzt werden
würde weil es unter die Sanktion
ausmaßnahmen fallen würden würde nur zum
zwei war noch nicht zertifiziert und man
hatte die Zertifizierung zu dem
Zeitpunkt schon ausgesetzt das heißt
auch da war absehbar dass diese
Pipelines absehbar kein Gas nach
Deutschland transportieren werden das
heißt man hat also vier Stränge wo
absehbar auch mit dem Krieg in der
Ukraine kein Gas mehr verkauft wird kann
ich das jetzt nutzen vielleicht um ein
psychologischen Effekt zu generieren
welche Effekte habe ich dadurch
generiert naja nach dem Anschlag auf die
nordsympipelines sind kurzfristig die
Energiepreise auf dem Markt nach oben
getrieben wir haben sehr viel
Verunsicherung wahrgenommen über
maritime kritische Infrastruktur das hat
ja auch dazu geführt dass wir jetzt
durch eine Studie zu diesem Thema
verfassen jeder in der Bevölkerung
spricht darüber es gibt unterschiedliche
Perspektiven Meinungen die sich
teilweise auch verhärten das könnte oder
ist wahrscheinlich sogar das Ziel dieses
Anschlags gewesen
da ist häufiger lese möchte ich auch
gerne noch mal nachfragen sie haben
gesagt und uns auch schon erklärt also
es ist ein staatlicher Akteur viel
wahrscheinlicher als Adresse als
Angreifer in dieser Sache aber ich lese
in den Kommentaren auch häufiger dass
ein anderer staatliche Akteur nämlich
die USA warum es nicht die hätten
gewesen sein können warum die daran kein
Interesse hätten haben Sie darauf eine
Antwort für uns
da gab es bereits Berichte von einem
amerikanischen Enthüllungsjournalisten
Simon Hirsch der darüber berichtete aus
einer einzigen Quelle hätte erfahren das
während der Übung boltops im Sommer im
Juni amerikanische Kräfte Sprengladung
angeblich angebracht hätten
das konnte er weder mit Beweisen
unterlegen und nun können wir einmal uns
diese Übung Botox im Detail noch
angucken diese Übung findet im Juni
immer statt in der Planung sind mehrere
100 Offiziere aus allen NATO-Staaten
involviert
dass man da etwas verdeckt plant halte
ich schon für unwahrscheinlich in der
Durchführung dann dieser Übung gibt es
ausgewiesene Gebiete gerade um Bornholm
herum die für militärische Übungen
genutzt werden aufbauen wollen selber
errichten die dänischen Behörden
Behörden für diesen Zeitraum extra eine
Infrastruktur zu Überwachung und für die
Sicherheit dieser Bereiche das heißt bei
der Übung während der Präsenz der
amerikanischen auch Streitkräfte in der
Ostsee für diese Übung habe ich einen
sehr gutes Lagebild durch dänische
Behörden aber auch schwedische Behörden
was da im Seeraum passiert da dann
verdeckt etwas durchzuführen wie es
diese Anschuldigung bisher
hervorgebracht hat haben halte ich für
sehr unwahrscheinlich und dann könnte
man nach der Intention nach dem Ziel
fragen warum würde man jetzt solch eine
Pipeline durch die eh kein Gas
transportiert wird aus amerikanischer
Sicht zerstören und wenn es herauskommt
dann eine Friktion eine Krise innerhalb
der NATO zwischen Partnern und Ängsten
Alliierten hervorrufen würde das Sinn
machen da habe ich bisher keine
Schlüssel hier Begründung gefunden sie
haben eben diese Übungen angesprochen wo
also auch viel Präsenz gezeigt wird von
der NATO einfach im auf See im Meer und
sie waren eben selbst jahrelang als
Fregattenkapitän bei NATO Übungen in der
Ostsee dabei haben die geleitet
teilweise die NATO zeigt ja dort also
Präsenz würden dann nicht aber eben auch
russische Schiffe die dort unterwegs
sind und dann vielleicht nicht
hingehören besonders auffallen
auch das ist normales Prozedere und habe
ich gerade gar nicht so ausgeführt haben
Sie aber einen richtigen Punkt gerade
während Ball Tops oder wenn
amerikanische Streitkräfte oder deutsche
Marineschiffe in der Ostsee unterwegs
sind werden sie oft begleitet durch
russische Kriegsschiffe das heißt
während dieser Übung Ball Tops ist es
normal das russische Kriegsschiffe
Spionage Schiffe oder andere
Forschungsschiffe in der Nähe sind und
beobachten was dort passiert das heißt
würden Amerikaner oder andere
Streitkräfte hier verdeckte Operationen
durchführen während die nicht lange
geheim jetzt arbeiten sie wir haben es
auch schon angesprochen eben ganz
aktuell an einer Studie die eben auch
die Sicherheit von unserer Infrastruktur
unter Wasser Infrastruktur einfach
besser darlegen schützen soll jetzt
endlich spannend auch dazu noch mal mehr
einzugehen aber vorher eben noch einen
eine weitere Kritik eine kritische Frage
von Thomas Melber bei Youtube der sich
noch mal fragt ob es denn Beweise dazu
gibt dass Russland jetzt so wie wir es
am Anfang der Sendung auch angesprochen
hatten also wirklich Unterseekabel und
Pipelines vermiet haben sollen er
schreibt ja möglich ist das aber gibt es
hier hierzu auch Beweise vorstellbar ist
vieles haben sie durch ihre Studie da
irgendwie noch mehr dazu erfahren was
was wir dem User hier antworten können
nein wir haben selber sind wir die
Pipelines und Kabelstränge nicht
abgetaucht und haben auch keine Minen
dort gefunden
wir haben aber sehr wohl beobachtet was
in den letzten Jahren passiert ist und
die Aktivitäten gerade auch russische
Kriegsschiffe Forschungsschiffe neuer
selbst entwickelter U-Boote unbemannter
Drohnen entlang kritischer Infrastruktur
und wir haben die Berichte die
mittlerweile aus der NATO auch von
offizieller Seite vorliegen was die
Times und andere Medien ja in den
letzten Tagen aufgegriffen haben und
wenn ich das übereinander lege dann sage
ich das was von der NATO präsentiert
wurde
ist plausibel und deckt sich mit dem was
wir auch in unserer Forschung in den
letzten Jahren gesammelt beobachtet
haben und den Daten waren Banken
zusammengeführt haben
und wenn wir jetzt mal darüber sprechen
wie sich das überhaupt schützen lässt
ich lese hier einen User Userin Moki 84
schreibt wie soll man Millionen
Kilometer Kabel überhaupt schützen
unmöglich meinte Userin sehen Sie das
genauso aussichtslos es ist wirklich bei
der Größe und Menge der maritimen
Infrastruktur nahezu unmöglich und die
maritime Infrastruktur wird ein Jahr
noch weiter zunehmen wir haben jetzt
Datenkabel wir haben Pipelines wir haben
Bohrinseln Offshore Windparks in Zukunft
sprechen wir auch von Einrichtungen zur
Speicherung von CO2 und der dem
Meeresboden und noch anderes ist möglich
das alles wirklich umfassend zu schützen
wird unmöglich sein
ich würde zwei Aspekte gleich zum Schutz
hier herausheben zum einen erstmal das
Lagebild verbessern dass wir wissen was
im Wasser und Unterwasser passiert die
verschiedensten Sensoren die es gibt
effektiver zu nutzen datenbilder aus
verschiedensten Quellen zusammenzuführen
und das zweite ist dann natürlich dass
wir erkennen dass es geographische
Ballungsgebiete maritimer Infrastruktur
gibt die Nordsee haben wir vorhin schon
ausgeführt dann gibt es Bereiche
westlich der britischen Inseln und auch
Irlands wo sehr viele Datenkabel über
den Atlantik laufen wir haben in der
Straße von Gibraltar haben wir sehr
viele Datenkabel gleichzeitig ist das
eine Engstelle für den internationalen
Warenverkehr und wir haben den Suezkanal
der auch ein Nadelöhr für den
Schiffsverkehrs und gleichzeitig auch
dort sehr viele Datenkabel verkaufen
wenn ich mich auf diese Ballungsräume
konzentriere weil ich dort natürlich
auch größeren Schaden erzeuge wenn ich
dort einen Sabotage
durchführe dann kann ich schon mal viele
Bereiche besser schützen ein einzelnes
Kabel eine einzelne Pipeline eine
einzelne Bohrinsel oder ein einzelner
Windpark werden uns nicht nachhaltig
schädigen diese Gefahr werde ich aber
nie ausschließen können und könnten aber
sogar noch mehr ich sag jetzt mal
Instrumente irgendwie zum Einsatz kommen
also könnten sie Blockaden ausgesprochen
werden bräuchte man vielleicht eine
richtige Einsatztruppe wenn ja wer wäre
das ist das überhaupt denkbar möglich
wem gehört das mehr also so viele Fragen
können Sie mir können Sie mir uns
vielleicht sagen also was man was kann
man noch alles machen darüber hinaus
also an erster Stelle würde ich
natürlich darauf verweisen dass man mehr
Präsenz auf die merkt mehr zeigt
insbesondere in diesem Ballungsräumen
maritimer kritischer Infrastruktur
gerade die Präsenz hat ja schon mal eine
abschreckende Wirkung und nun können wir
so ein bisschen die Vergangenheit gucken
nach den Anschlägen vom 11 September
2001 gab es auch auf oder
maritimen showpoints in diesen
Engstellen bestimmte Operationen von der
NATO aber auch später von der EU um zum
Beispiel den Schiffsverkehr zu schützen
das sind so ein beispielgebende
Operationen die man nehmen kann wenn man
jetzt in diese Ballungsräume maritimer
Infrastruktur schaut um das Lagebild zu
verbessern natürlich haben wir
verschiedene Rechtsräume Maritim im Raum
wir haben die territorial Gewässer wir
haben die daran anschließende
ausschließliche Wirtschaftszone und wir
haben die hohe See gerade aus deutscher
Sicht sind ja auch verschiedene
Zuständigkeiten und Verantwortlichkeiten
in dem verschiedenen Räumen das heißt
ich muss das auch mit den verschiedenen
Akteuren das heißt Landespolizei
Bundespolizei oder auch Seestreitkräften
zusammenbringen dass diese zusammen
diese Infrastruktur dann auch schützen
das eine ist das schützen das andere
natürlich die Aufklärung zum Schluss
noch die Frage wie optimistisch sind Sie
dass die Angriffe auf die Pipeline Nord
Stream eins zwei dass sie jemals
aufgeklärt werden
ich glaube nicht dass wir innerhalb der
nächsten Tage oder Wochen deinen
abschließendes Untersuchungsergebnis
haben werden wir wissen dass derzeitig
noch durch insbesondere schwedische
Behörden eine
Olli Sprengstoffe die man gefunden hat
analysiert werden das könnten weitere
Indikatoren sein und es ist natürlich
vorstellbar und möglich das will ich
auch nicht ausschließen dass über den
Lauf Verlauf der Zeit auch noch mehr
Informationen die heute noch gar nicht
absehbar bekannt werden ich halte es
auch für vorstellbar dass irgendwann
einzelne Beteiligte Leute sich auch an
die Öffentlichkeit wenden um ihr
Gewissen zu entlasten oder weil sie
damit Geld verdienen das ist ja auch ein
Phänomen was wir heutzutage immer wieder
wahrnehmen und somit möchte ich am Ende
auch gar nicht ausschließen dass wir
irgendwann einmal ein umfassendes Bild
über diese Vorgänge an den Pipelines
haben werden
vielen Dank für die viele Erklärung für
die vielen Fragen die sie uns
beantwortet haben da waren viele
Informationen drin danke an Fregatten
Kapitän Göhren danke
auch an euch für die vielen Fragen ich
hoffe ich konnte die allermeisten davon
mit hier in diese Sendung nehmen seid
gerne auch beim nächsten Mal wieder
dabei bis dahin erstmal einen schönen
Abend und tschüss